no you're right over there Joey Porto's
is the number one restaurant in
California pornos it's called yeah
where's it at okay clean Bob it looks
good next time I come up I'm bringing my
boy these red things in there what is
that those peppers and the board in the
tray in the tray what is that
Oh wrapper what is that I can't see what
that is I understand I ate two deluxe
spicy chicken sandwiches I'm not gonna
be hungry I didn't I didn't think of
that I would have went to in and out you
know more supportive any diversity in
consciously Coria their cousins was
going Alex Trump boy accompany the
president it wasn't the president of CEO
Goya said something in support of Donald
Trump and now people are going crazy
Porto Rican is on fire right now
Spanish people having a great week cuz I
don't know if you know our netflix they
released the Walter McDonald documentary
minutes
Jorge Maz Vidal fights the walk mob look
at that Mazda now he's fighting the walk
mob I'm sure he did but uh goes well
these boys this week they released this
documentary Joe Rogan this is what every
Spanish person has grown up with can you
get it for me Jim if you can it's called
mucho or more it's the documentary and
Walter makaula
and wait you see this [ __ ] beauty Joe
Rogan wait till you see this guy this
guy was the Buddha star in the world guy
yes come on it's a Netflix queue Man 3
laying this person or is that the actual
person that's the person what is that it
bro this is you gotta see the scam this
is a guy this is a guy Joe Rogan this
thing will blow your [ __ ] mind he was
the biggest Latin star in the world
people begged for him he gave horoscopes
but he gave her became a giant star
water your horoscopes he would just give
you heartless corpse I'm all I'm Morley
mas I'm older he would just give you
horoscopes and [ __ ] Walter Mercado so
Telemundo picked them up Howard Stern
even Howard Stern said to him you're the
Jesus of Spanish people because I'm not
as big as Jesus I just you know but you
got the whole documentary is the rise
and fall of welcome 'god i never heard
of this kind of can use what is real on
this fam the trailer what does he do
what's his thing he I just told you yeah
but Horace Cole is not just horoscopes
horoscopes Scorpio you are very
determined and you look at the mother
Howard Stern that's insane
dogs I give your Spanish you grew up on
them and not you don't know you weren't
allowed to talk this guy really if your
mom on your mom would say hold on
because you had to wait be a sign he
would tell you the sign of the day oh my
god that's also you like oh [ __ ] I'm
gonna hit the number I'm gonna put it
I'm gonna go you know it's a good Porter
Rico this
I was his manager the guy stole his
identity from him had him just sign over
on his face his character and his name
he found that far isn't it yeah he got
him for 14 million dollars [ __ ]
tremendous he had nothing but gapes this
[ __ ] nobody ever said a word
about it as he got older look at his
face holy yeah when I'm gonna radar
Walter McDonald tremendous Wow so
Spanish people were having a good
[ __ ] week
they're like god damn and [ __ ] and then
[ __ ] go you had to [ __ ] it up for
everybody
mucho mucho amor damn I mean that's all
the gore guy did is he said something
pro-trump that's it that's it that's
what you have to do Porto Ricans like
you know what they've kind of like you
know they've stolen from the Puerto
Ricans and then Trump didn't help the
Puerto Ricans with all the hurricane
stuff and now you gonna side with them
that's how they felt you know I'm the
war was Trump's statement about Puerto
Rico there was something about how it
corrupt everything was over there and
that they did help but the problem was
corruption in Puerto Rico
whenever there is a national disaster
there's always corruption okay hmm
this is a national disaster wait to the
corruption to start soon as Catina who
went to jail will Katrina de Maya the
man that's big money jack Katrina
everybody was supposed to get the first
wave the mayor went to jail after
Katrina New Orleans check it out I
didn't Harlequin American gentlemen
leave a [ __ ] dip double dipping they
get greedy when the national disaster
comes